The great thing about the horror genre is
the range of styles it encompasses.
Everyone's afraid of something, and some of
those unique fears have inspired amazing movies.
While horror flicks often come with a sizable
body count, there's more to the genre than
just a well-stocked list of victims.
From ghostly apparitions that haunt families
to the knowledge of someone stalking you,
here are the scariest horror movies where
no one actually gets offed on screen.
Obviously, there are a whole bunch of spoilers
ahead!
Poltergeist
One of the most terrifying ghost story movies
of all time, Poltergeist has been parodied,
referenced, and even remade, but nothing can
detract from the genuinely frightening visuals
and invasive horror of the film.
"They're here!"
Luckily for the film's central family, no
one actually gets offed in Poltergeist.
They're ultimately able to escape with their
lives intact, although they lose the safe
sanctuary that their home represented.
Some would say that that's even scarier than
that truly horrific clown doll.
The Others
Outwardly a horror movie about a haunted house,
the real terror of The Others is in being
trapped and battered by forces you cannot
comprehend.
As it turns out, the family living in fear
of ghosts are themselves the ghosts.
What they believed to be the ghosts were,
in fact, the new owners of the house.
It's a twist that flips horror movie conventions
on their heads, showcasing how horrific a
ghost story can be — even for the ghost.
And since the main family members were actually
ghosts the whole time, no lives are taken
in the movie itself.
The Babadook
Like all the best horror movies, The Babadook
lets the central monster become symbolic for
any number of horrific real-life experiences,
like trauma, loneliness, and mental illness.
The symbolic weight of the film doesn't drag
the film down into maudlin subtext, though
— you can enjoy it as a simple movie about
a single mother trying to keep her son safe.
In spite of its frights, the characters make
it out alive in The Babadook, although viewers
squeamish about ill-fated family pets should
steer clear.
Based on one of Stephen King's short stories,
1408 has a simple hook that's hard to beat:
After the loss of his young daughter, a skeptic
rents a haunted hotel room to prove that ghosts
don't exist.
"This is it?
You gotta be kidding me."
The horror in the film doesn't come from Mike's
fear of the ghosts but from his experiences
within a twisted reality where he can't trust
his senses or even himself.
Despite the room's consistent encouragement
for him to take his own life, Mike ends up
living through the final credits.
One Hour Photo
Robin Williams is absolutely chilling as a
voyeuristic stalker in One Hour Photo.
The film follows Williams' character as he
becomes obsessed with a family after developing
their photos.
When he discovers the family isn't as perfect
as he had believed, he begins stalking and
even threatening them.
The movie works in the horror genre precisely
because of its creepy central character, the
kind of person you immediately forget about
after you leave your local store.
Still, despite his creepy behavior, this obsessive
stalker doesn't actually take any lives in
the film.
Signs
At one point in time, director M. Night Shyamalan
was the king of the plot twist.
And while it might not be The Sixth Sense,
Signs is a surprisingly effective horror movie.
The film follows a family whose grief at the
loss of their matriarch is interrupted by
an alien invasion.
The horror is restrained, blending the family's
questioning faith with the arrival of alien
conquerors so seamlessly that some fans have
theorized that the aliens are actually demons.
Whether the monsters are aliens or demons,
they're equally ineffective at taking any
lives in the film.
April Fool's Day
The only slasher film on this list, April
Fool's Day follows a group of friends who
go on a weekend trip full of pranks and practical
jokes to celebrate April Fool's Day.
Despite corpses piling up and lots of blood,
there are actually no real victims in the
film.
As it turns out, each supposed victim was
actually in on the joke, helping to craft
a specialized horror resort.
"Oh, ha ha.
(Tidus from Final Fantasy X Impression)
That's really funny, you guys!"
Even a fake out finale ends up being nothing
more than a practical joke, making this the
bloodiest casualty-free movie we can think
of.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!